everywhere you look the world is out of
order and it's all happening on Joe
Biden's watch his administration
scrambling to avert Financial Armageddon
after two big banks failed and shocking
new video shows the moment a Russian
fighter jet taunted one of our drones
before smashing right into it there's a
lot of serious stuff going on right now
but what are our leaders up to
Kamala is giggling her heart out on
liberal Late Night with Stephen Colbert
and guess what she thinks the biggest
issue is
what are going to be the major issues
that will Define this election I think
it will be as the president has said
about
seeing it through
and building on the momentum that we
have achieved thus far I mean think
about it in only the last two years
we have by my estimate with the bills
and the legislation that we have passed
we are putting up to one trillion
dollars on the streets of America on the
issue of the climate crisis around
investment in resilience and adaptation
so Kamala thinks climate change is our
biggest threat and while the rest of the
world crumbles have no fear she says we
have an extraordinary leader in the
White House
he is an extraordinary leader and I wish
that people could see what I see because
there's only one person who sits behind
that Resolute desk
and the decisions that that person has
to make are the decisions that nobody
else in the country can make
but the lunacy doesn't stop there we all
know kabbalah is the real life version
of the show Veep with her endless string
of awkward moments word salads and
comical mishaps and she just confirmed
it
is it accurate there is there are bits
of it that are actually quite quite
accurate what is the actual role on a
daily basis as you have found it well I
have the great privilege of serving with
Joe Biden who was president of the
United States it's an excellent that's
an excellent answer and uh the question
was what is the job of the vice
president
and your answer is part of the job I'm
guessing well you know my job is to do I
mean for example I'll tell you um I was
recently in Munich at the Munich
security conference and um
the amazing part of this is that you
have a woman Jesse who is the vice
president of the United States she's in
charge of the Border abortion rights and
voting rights there's a million things
she could have said as to what the vice
president does and you know Colbert gave
her a second chance at it the woman
can't even describe it well you know
when you go on these shows it's
choreographed especially if you're the
vice president so you get the
pre-interview and then you get another
pre-interview so she knows exactly what
questions are being asked but she was
the one that brought Veep up
now everyone
disparagingly Associates her with Veep
she was the one that introduced Veep
into the conversation with Colver which
makes no sense to me and he tried to
rescue her and then she told the story
about how VP it was at the White House
and some guy set a fire in the fireplace
and didn't pull the flu out so it got a
little smoky and then she cackled
hysterically it wasn't even funny so she
says she wants to fight the climate and
that's going to be the biggest theme and
then she said abortion next and then she
went after DeSantis on Ukraine but I
have a feeling she'd say whatever the
audience wanted to hear this is a late
night audience this is targeting younger
people so those are the kind of things
she wanted to hit you can tell the
ground is Shifting though because you
have Jets kind of colliding with our
drones you have the banking system kind
of teetering and Joe Biden hasn't even
announced whether he's running for
president or not so this is kind of the
relaunch for Kamala will maybe the the
re-re-re relaunch
the Rebrand she's going to Iowa today it
looks like she's trying to say I'm on
this ticket whether anybody likes it or
not and this is what I'm all about you
know Harold on the night that we're
dealing with a provocation by a Russian
jet you know dumping fuel on our drone
and and hitting it there's no question
it was provocation by a Russian jet she
Dre she brags about putting a trillion
dollars into the economy which was the
beginning of the inflation Trend that we
have in the United States as if that was
some great thing that happened it's like
she's clueless as to what she thinks is
wonderful
great to be back around the table two I
think that she uh I would have probably
scripted that a little differently
talking about the accomplishments of the
administration the things that we have
to be looking forward to
um but you know my politics is a little
different so I would have I would have
certainly handled it differently and I
think as we think about those three
things that are so critical to the
country right now if I were her I'd have
said you know look this banking
situation is serious uh the president
will speak for us as it relates to how
we feel about interest rates but in no
time in our history has the FED uh been
successful in fighting inflation and
fighting a banking crisis at the same
time so they're going to have to deal
with that two this is no time to be
messing around with the debt selling if
you think a little Bank out in
California and no one had heard of who
had a bunch of idiosyncratic accounts
could do this put this kind of stress on
our markets and just kind of stress in
our economy imagine what happens if we
call in the question of Full Faith and
Credit of the United States politics has
to be taken out of it in three if she
wanted to play the politics which
clearly there was something to play
around Ukraine and I do think the
governor DeSantis has is where I'm from
we said those plain to do about why he
feels that way and he should if he
believes that he should defend it but I
think this Russian drone thing has a
little bit of it has to do with how
we're performing in Ukraine and the fact
that we are considering and it was
announced today that one of our European
allies has decided to provide more
Weaponry to the ukrainians we should be
doing the same thing I believe I've said
on this show and others whatever weapons
whatever technology is needed by the
ukrainians we should be in the business
of supporting we've not lost any
American and I think we're we're
advancing against Putin or at least we
have shown Putin that you can't come
into a country and take it because I
think the fundamental question is he
won't stop there uh and anyone who
believes that he would I think I'd love
to hear the explanation but I don't
disagree with you I would have had a
better script than what she had Dana the
interesting part of Harold's answer was
a discussion of the substance of what's
going on in Ukraine you know that we are
literally depleting our military
equipment so that they can fight the war
as opposed to even discussing this she
talks about the fact that when she talks
about Ukraine she talks about how she's
met with leaders yeah and she got to go
to the Munich conference yeah and that
was and she gave a decent speech there
of course but it is it is pretty
remarkable that you don't have those
talking points down I have the talking
points down I've watched the State of
the Union speech the president said
finish the job 27 times that's the
talking point and then you go through
the list blah blah blah they just did
the gun executive order there's so many
things that she could have said what I
think is pretty funny is that she thinks
that her job is like a real life version
of V but imagine the writers of Veep who
thought they were writing a comedy and
it turns out they were writing a
documentary that could have been on
Netflix she also says that the most
important issue is climate change why
does she say that well because she
thinks the young people are going to
stick with her on that but remember this
is the same person she married to the
first the second gentleman the first
second gentleman we've ever had and what
is his main issue that he is thinks is
the worst thing that is going on toxic
masculinity and that's what he said he's
going to use his platform for so the
thing about Julia Louis Dreyfus on Veep
she plays a character that is shallow
incompetent disingenuous rude
and
an embarrassment to the United States I
would not have made the comparison you
know Greg I've never watched the show
Veep so I can't speak to it but if if
Dina's right and it's a documentary of
as opposed to a comedy I mean the
question really is right now she is in
they say a grudge match uh not with
Elizabeth Warren apparently they had
dinner last night uh but with Newsome
that they're both fighting to be the
next person in line what say you about
that I don't know I'm just jealous I'm
so jealous to be able to feel drunk all
the time without ever drinking I mean
every time you listen to her she sounds
like a woman at a bar on her fourth
skinny margarita yeah and she never has
to pay it's like inner bloodstream the
whole time I was wondering if she took
the comparison to Veep as a compliment
right like she's like she she didn't
really understand that the whole show is
about a failure I mean it's like someone
comparing your driving to Ted Kennedy's
you know she didn't like she would say
well I would say hold on the only person
dumber than her is her husband I mean
the guy who compared you know compared
the parents who were angry at a school
board to what happened before the
Holocaust I mean that's worse than toxic
masculinity he could combine the things
he says with her and he they could go
out as a team and they could say climate
is the most important issue and if you
disagree with me you're worse than
Hitler I think you know climate hysteria
is a religion for lazy people in it you
can talk about sacrifice and you can
sound Noble but you actually don't
sacrifice right it's for other people
not you so you can talk about all these
things and be an advocate but you can
still fly private so I'm very suspicious
I'm always suspicious and I think people
are becoming suspicious of the climate
religion because it's an ideology that
becomes an answer for everything which
means it's an answer for nothing uh it's
in a way uh there's a phrase in TV
called jump the shark yeah well in this
case I believe she shot the zebra Jesse
she shot the zebra that's when you
introduce something into a segment that
shocks the viewer and disappoints all of
your supporters
is that what that means yes okay well
like Kamala who also didn't see me yeah
I didn't see that it did and didn't get
it I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now